Hey, what's up guys Grant here, popping in with another subscriber giveaway
I went down and picked up a Nintendo switch with Mario Kart 8
I'd like to give it to one of you so I got a link down in the description for some subscriber appreciation
We'll see you there. Hey guys, I'm Nate and today we've got a fun experiment
We're going to try and see if we can make our very own magnetic putty.
There's a couple different methods we're gonna try and both of them involve using this synthetic iron oxide also called
magnetite, this whole one-pound bag is available on Amazon for less than ten bucks
and it goes a long way. As the first experiment
I have a little blob of silly putty and we're just gonna see what happens if we mix some of our magnetite powder
Into the silly putty. Now this bag is full of magnetic powder and you can see that a magnet does stick to it quite well
I don't want to get any of the magnetic powder directly on the magnet because it's a very fine grain powder
It would be nearly impossible to get it all off
But, I'll try pouring some onto a plate and then playing with the powder a little bit with our magnet under the, plate and [can you] see
It's a very fine powder
It does have some clumps and those break up into just dust, really
You can see how dark this stuff is and that does transfer onto your skin. If you touch this stuff with your bare skin like
It's just like charcoal dust it it gets, it gets on you. It just kind of likes to stay on
Alright, so there is our black magnetic powder. Let's see what happens if we bring our magnet
Underneath it on the plate
Cool little
Shards spike things forming pretty similar to what happened when we made our ferrofluid except in this case,  it's not a fluid
It's just a powder
we've got our magnetic powder and we've got a little bit of silly putty if you're not familiar with silly putty, it's a a
Rubbery gooey substance that is like an extremely, extremely thick liquid
So this is already a pretty neat putty I want to see what happens if we mix a bunch of our
Magnetite powder into this, and see if we can get a magnetic putty that way
[Rubbing it in reeaaalll nice]
hoi youtube
Okay at this point our putty is completely black there's no trace of orange coloring left to it
so the magnetite powder has really
Overpowered all the orange color that was in it. Let's see how well this is attracted to a magnet. Oh, I would say definitely
Definitely more attracted and now it's sort of just jumps up to it
One of the things I've seen done with commercial magnetic putty is you can put some of it near a magnet and it sort of
Just swallows the magnet whole this is a pretty powerful magnet. So, let's see if we can get that result using this putty
Despite leaving our homemade magnetic putty next to a magnet for a while
It didn't ever really envelop the magnet it started grabbing on to one end of it and then just kind of stopped
I think the silly putty itself is just a little bit too rigid and durable and then when you add in the magnetite it gets even
More rigid by just a little bit and in the end
It's so hard that it doesn't really like to move very much. Another cool little thing
You can do with magnetic putty often is pull a little strand away from the main blob using the magnet
And again, it's attracted to it
But it doesn't really pull it hard enough that it can stretch out very well while having black silly putty that's pretty much normal
But it's attracted to a magnet might be cool, it's not really what we're going for so
Let's see if we can use a different recipe and make a slightly softer putty
One recipe I've seen says you can use two parts multi-purpose white glue and one part
Laundry starch and we're gonna add one part of our magnetite powder to that as well
Let's see what we can get using that
This won't make a very large batch
But it might be about the same as the size of our silly putty glob so it'll be a good comparison
This is not a very smooth texture at this point
But I'm going to keep working it and see if it gets any better and it is already getting a little bit stiffer
So I think that's a good sign. It's still very sticky though
It might just because it likes to stick to the rubber on my gloves. I'm gonna try this without gloves
Mmm, sticky on my hands as well. Not just the gloves
Assuming the sticky is from the glue
Maybe adding a little bit more starch will stop it from being is sticky
Maybe this recipe is just really really sticky
That seems to be helping and it's still we ewey guggy
but it's not sticking to my hands nearly as much so I think it's just getting
Just the right balance of starch and glue because now this is turning into a putty that I can actually handle a little bit
So now we know if we're mixing our glue and our starch and it's too sticky
We just need to add a tiny bit more starch not even a lot
I just dipped it down in on one spot a little bit and now I can handle this and it like
There's really not sticking it to my hands anymore
If you want to make homemade silly putty I'd say this is a pretty good recipe
It is a little bit thinner, but it's pretty similar. I wonder if I can bounce the ball of this stuff
hmm not on this material just stuck right to it
a little it bounces off the workbench
Not as high of a bounce of silly putty, but a bounce
All right. Let's try adding our magnetite powder to this and I'm going to try and
Add about one spoonful
I think we have a good puddy
The question is whether we have a good magnetic putty let's grab our magnet and see how well it's attracted to it
Oooh, I would call that pretty attracted
Let's try the same test
We do the silly putty let's just make a ball and see how easily it moves to the magnet
It jumps right out of my hand nicely putting the magnet near it it immediately starts stretching out and grab onto it
The silly putty itself didn't do much to grab around the magnet
Let's see what happens if we just leave this putty near the magnet for a few minutes
That did a much better job than the silly putty it reached all the way around our magnet this magnet
Compared to the weight of the putty is probably too big for it to move with its own magnetic draw
but some of the putty reached
Over the top of the magnet and down in front and grabbed on to that side, too
So really did a pretty good job of enveloping the magnet. This works pretty well
it's a good magnetic putty I think the natural step at this point is
to make a lot more
magnetic putty
We now have one big old blob of putty
This is a there's a lot of do right here. You just let it sit for a second. It just starts stretching yourself out
Slowly slowly stretching yourself out so
Now we want to try and turn this into this
And we're just gonna pour our powder on top of it all around it. My hands are gonna end up so black from this
See
I'm black already
We now have a pretty giant blob of our putty let's do a test and see how magnetic it is
That's it's definitely sticking
And of course this blob weighs way more than our magnet and so it doesn't just get lifted up into the air just
sort of
Grabs at a portion of it, whatever's closest to it and stretches that out
Let's try watching our magnetic putty swallow some of our powerful magnets
I would definitely call this experimental success mixing the magnetite powder with silly putty not so much
It is magnetic, but it's too stiff to really react to the magnets
But using our homemade putty made from white glue and liquid starch
We were able to make a perfect consistency of putty so that when we mix the magnetite powder into it it reacts
Really? Well with the magnet, I mean the magnet gets drawn onto it it sticks to it
It pulls the putty away from the blob and of course if we put the blob in the putty
It just gets swallowed and you can see this is in real time
I'm not speeding up this footage like the magnet just gets drawn down into this stuff really quickly
Of course, this is an extremely powerful magnet, but we have a lot of magnetic putty so it seemed fitting to me guys
There's still more for you to see that little box up the top will transport you directly to our last video go check it out
That box at the bottom will show you what YouTube thinks you should be watching next and if you hit this bomb in the center
You'll be subscribed to the channel. So you never miss another video again
Don't forget to ring that Bell and we'll see you in the next one talk to then